Peach,
join me and welcome Catherine
[inaudible].
Thank
you so much victor,
and it is so good to be with you all here today.
Um,
we are delighted to be here at Google during Google gives week and I know coming
from a nonprofit and technology background how much the community here at Google
has done to support important efforts around the world and we're so appreciative
at the Wikimedia foundation of all of the support that you have shown and given
to us over the years.
And thank you so much to victor and the whole team for reaching out.
Uh,
so it's a funny story about how I got here today.
As many of you probably know Wikipedia is written by volunteers.
What you probably don't know is that our helpline is also operated by
volunteers.
And when victor reached out last year to see if we were able to attend that
request,
didn't quite make it through the queue in time for us to be here in December.
But we are delighted that he reached out again this year.
And then I'm here with you today.
So thank you so much.
All right,
so I'm here to tell you a little story about Wikipedia since it started in 2001
Wikipedia has grown into one of the world's most popular and beloved websites
used by hundreds of millions of people and hundreds of languages all over the
world every single month.
We're a little unusual in that we are a nonprofit and always will be around
Wikipedia.
We have a popular saying that the problem with Wikipedia is that it only works
in practice because in theory it would be a total disaster.
Think about it.
How on earth would you get all of these people from all of these backgrounds,
languages,
and perspectives to come together to agree on anything much less a neutral
version of truth?
Um,
it's a good question and I'm going to tell you a little bit about how we do that
over the course of my talk.
But first,
before I do that,
I want to tell you a little bit about how we came to be in 2001 this guy,
Jimmy Wales,
had an idea.
He's a bit of a nerd,
bit of a Geek,
and then somebody who has always loved learning.
One of my favorite images of Jimmy is actually from when he was a child,
four years old with an encyclopedia in hand.
Unfortunately,
I can't show it here because it's not freely licensed and I will explain a
little bit about our passion for that,
but this photo is so Jimmy little bit of a nerd was fascinated by the way the
internet worked back in the 80s and he'd been observing the open software
movement and he'd also been thinking a lot about how he could think how to,
with knowledge and thinking about how a resource like Wikipedia could begin to
grow at this,
or sorry,
an encyclopedia could grow at the scale of the Internet.
As I mentioned,
he was also a little bit of a Geek and fascinated by the open source movement,
particularly interested in Linus is law given enough eyeballs.
All bugs are shallow.
He was interested in how you could bring a project that wasn't software but
information into being with many participants and no owners.
So I'll tell you a little secret.
His first effort failed new pedia was the precursor to Wikipedia.
It was also an encyclopedia based on a traditional peer reviewed model that
anyone could contribute to subject to a rigorous seven step approval process in
the first year 12 articles where creative
if failed,
Jimmy will be the first to admit this.
Well Jimmy and his team were trying to think about how to accelerate the
contribution of articles too.
We are too new pedia they created this side site.
It was a Wiki.
They thought people could add articles there and continue to work on them over
time.
It was based on Wiki technology,
which at the time was really new.
It was trying to solve for a problem that at that point in time hadn't been
solved for.
How do you publish quickly to the Internet?
I mean today that sounds like a relatively easy thing.
We've gotten come a long way,
but at the time this was a pretty exciting thing and so they created a Wiki is
sort of a holding pen for articles where people could add and improve and
update.
Uh,
the Wiki bus is wiki comes from a Hawaiian word Wiki Wiki,
which means quick,
I'm like editing quickly on the web.
And so that,
that is actually the bus that gets you from Honolulu airport to anywhere you
need to go pretty quickly.
So this Wiki was a smashing success in the first year,
18,000 articles were created,
which is probably why you've never heard of new pedia.
Jimmy and his team recognizing a good thing quickly pivoted.
And by the end of the year Wikipedia had been born.
This is the homepage in December,
2001 it looks kind of the same
but a little different,
a little different.
Um,
as you can see it has articles about very high minded encyclopedic type stuff
like mathematics,
astronomy,
philosophy.
But it wasn't all science and it wasn't all traditional encyclopedic content.
It in the early days Wikipedia,
it was pretty wild.
And Willy and as you know,
anyone could add anything.
This is one of my favorite first drafts of history.
This is the article for the standard poodle,
and I know you can't see it,
but it is a dog by which all others are measured.
So today this is the article for the standard poodle,
actually just a poodle.
And as you can see,
it's like most Wikipedia articles.
It's well sourced,
it's well cited,
it's comprehensive,
it has a tremendous amount of knowledge.
It's updated over time and,
and,
and the UX has changed somewhat.
So the idea took off rather quickly.
In January of 2001 Wikipedia started with English.
And thanks to the efforts of polyglot editors around the world.
It grew by March,
2001 it was in German,
[inaudible] and Japanese
by May,
2001 it was in some of the world's largest and smaller languages.
And today we support nearly 300 languages in Wikipedia is large and small from
English Wikipedia,
which has 5 million articles and growing to some of the smaller Wikipedia is
like also Wikipedia,
which has about a thousand articles.
And over the course of an average month,
we receive a lot of visitors today about one and a half billion unique devices
come to Wikipedia every single month.
Now,
I don't have an exact unique user count,
which I think is a little unusual.
Um,
at Wikipedia,
we're very conscious of privacy and so we just track the devices as opposed to
the new unique users.
But we know that that represents a really significant portion of the world.
So I've told you a little bit about where we come from,
but how does it all work?
Getting back to that idea that it's a disaster in theory,
but somehow it works in practice.
Okay.
I think what underlies Wikipedia at the very heart is this fundamental idea that
more people want to do good than harm.
More people want to create knowledge,
then destroy,
and more people want to share then to contain.
At its core,
Wikipedia is about human generosity.
But of course there are some really specific things that make it possible to,
the first is keeping it open.
Famously,
Wikipedia is the encyclopedia that everyone can edit and over time a very
significant portion of the population has on English,
Wikipedia alone.
We know that 6 million people have contributed to articles over its 15 year
history and that is just registered users.
As you may know,
you don't even have to register to edit Wikipedia.
All you have to do is click edit.
Okay,
you can come,
you can fix something and you can move on.
We'll never know who you were or where you came from and that's a huge part of
why it works.
It's also open in the sense that everything that we do in terms of our engine,
our platform underlying it is open.
It's based on open source technology and someone,
anyone can come along and add a patch or a contribution.
We really appreciate this.
It's the only way that we could scale to the number of users that we support in
the way that we do.
Okay,
and it's open,
licensed.
Anybody can use the content,
reuse the content or remix the content on any of the wiki media sites.
It's why you see content from Wikipedia all over the Internet.
No matter where you go for commercial and noncommercial purposes,
it's core to who we are.
We also believe in letting people make the rules.
No one owns Wikipedia.
Literally.
As I said,
all of the content is open.
All the licensing is open,
so I'm here from the Wikimedia foundation.
Then we'll chat a little bit about that,
but what most people don't know is we're not in charge of editorial policy.
The people are volunteer.
Editors have set the policies over time.
They decide who's in,
who's out,
what's notable,
what's not,
what gets to stay on Wikipedia.
They set the standards for how to uphold our mission and what are the cores of
those policies.
If you want to edit Wikipedia today,
these are the three core policies that you need to know.
There are a lot,
there's a lot more to it.
Of course there are five pillars of Wikipedia and there were more than 70 pages
of essays and things that you can learn about best practices for every
conceivable type of article you might want to write,
but these are the three that gets you started.
The first is verifiability.
Every single piece,
every single statement on Wikipedia needs to be cited to a secondary source.
You need to be able to find out where it came from and go back and verify it.
This is critical to who we are.
If Wikipedia was just an article with no way to check the citations,
you wouldn't know how to trust it,
but Wikipedia makes an implicit promise that if it's on there,
you can go and check and make sure that it's real neutral point of view.
Many of the subjects that Wikipedia covers are controversial from climate change
to the Israeli Palestinian conflict.
How do you write about these things in such a way that brings people together
and finds common truth and fact mutual point of view.
It means that you can cover controversy but you don't engage in it.
On the article about climate change.
I always find it fascinating.
It's about
nine tenths of the articles about science.
And one 10th of the article is about the controversy.
Wikipedians don't believe in objectivity.
Both sides have equal standing.
They believe in neutrality,
they present the facts as they exist in the world.
And of course no original research while knowledge is being created every single
day until it has been published by reliable secondary source.
It doesn't belong on Wikipedia.
There's also this rule to ignore all rules,
but that's like very advanced Wikipedia stuff.
So,
uh,
if you want to get into editing Wikipedia,
I suggest strongly by starting with these three and,
and working your way up to that one.
And then there's this aspect of Wikipedia that I love and I don't think it gets
nearly enough attention.
It's that we are completely relentlessly embed our,
um,
transparent.
I was going to say embarrassingly transparent,
but that is true to
all of our errors.
I think there's an article about hoaxes on Wikipedia.
We are tremendously transparent in everything that we do.
Every edit that has ever been added to Wikipedia.
Every revision that has ever been made,
every piece of code,
every patch that's ever been submitted,
it's all there in public because transparency is a promise to our users that
they know who we are and where we're coming from.
Transparency allows us to easily ferret out bias,
subtle or otherwise,
and address it effectively and in time.
It allows us to account for when we fail in our mission,
transparency is critical to preserving trust between us and our users.
And we would never have it any other way,
even if it does mean sometimes some of those ugly bits hangout.
So I mentioned earlier,
nobody owns Wikipedia and so if nobody owns Wikipedia,
who am I?
And what am I doing here?
Good question.
Right?
Um,
I am the executive director of the Wikimedia foundation.
The Wikimedia foundation is a nonprofit organization.
We're based in downtown San Francisco.
That's our office right down on new Montgomery Street.
You're welcome to come by.
Anytime we were established in 2003 or as we like to say,
joined Wikipedia in 2003 after it was created to support and steward the sites
and make sure that we could support the contributors all over the world that
make them possible.
We are 277 people,
which is a lot for a nonprofit,
but very small for an organization that serves the number of people that we do
at the scale that we do.
So what did we do?
Some of this will be familiar to you.
I was chatting with victor before coming onstage and he said,
Oh yeah,
your breakdown of engineer's to other people.
That sounds like about right for any tech company.
Well,
we operate the technology that makes Wikepedia possible.
We run our own servers and roll our own DNS.
We do it all and contribute our part to the free and decentralized web.
It's critically important to us.
We engineered privacy,
security and speed into everything that we do.
As I mentioned,
we don't collect a lot of user data.
We want to make sure that whenever you use Wikipedia from,
no matter where you are in the world that your browsing history is secure and
private.
We want to make sure that it's fast no matter where you are.
If you're sitting here in mountain view on your smartphone or if you're on a
dial up connection with an old desktop box running IEE six,
we need to make sure that Wikipedia works for you.
Okay.
And a lot of people do use it.
Old dial up connections in desktop boxes.
Let me tell you,
you guys probably know we build new features for users.
So I showed you the standard poodle article earlier and you can see that it has
evolved over time.
We've also evolved from editing in Wiki text into editing with a beautiful new
visual editor that allows you to write just as you were on a word processor.
We've introduced new uploaders to make access to content easier for folks to
share,
new editing interfaces,
messaging and collaboration tools and viewing experiences.
There's a lot that goes on behind the scenes and I love this one because I think
it's critical to who we are and our values.
We defend our contributors and we defend our content against legal threats.
We have a fund that supports contributors off from all,
all over the world when they are subject to harassment or threats,
we fight,
take down an alteration notices for content and for lawsuits that would be
frivolous or unjustified or otherwise infringe upon freedom of expression and
freedom of the right to access information.
It's critical to who we are and what we stand for.
Okay?
And we support the communities that make Wikipedia possible.
As I mentioned,
we've been edited by millions of people over the world.
Every single month,
tens of thousands of people edit Wikipedia.
On average it's about 80 to 85,000 but that number goes up and down.
Over time people stop in,
we'll make an edit,
they'll come back.
But we have a really passionate core community of people who make Wikipedia
possible.
We have 37 stewards give or take with sudo access to our sites,
which sounds crazy and it is,
but it's also core to who we are and we support them through training and other
resources.
We have a hundred affiliate organizations made up of users who are passionate
about Wikipedia all over the world.
They engage in partnerships and outreach,
edit Athens,
uh,
collaborations with museums and in educational institutions and rerun,
we run workshops and trainings and give away 10% of our annual budget in grants
every year to support their efforts.
And of course,
we raised the funds to support with a media.
We're in the bit middle of a big fundraiser.
As you may have noticed,
if you've been on our site lately,
you've seen the banners,
they persist until you give.
So thank you for your contribution.
Every year we raised the money to keep Wikipedia going.
Um,
the support of donors is critical to who we are.
And actually this year we launched an endowment campaign,
uh,
for $100 million in order to keep Wikipedia safe and thriving and growing in
perpetuity because we know that Wikipedia is more than just this year.
Wikipedia is an incredible human accomplishment that deserves to be safe
forever.
And who are these incredibly generous people who give to us?
Well,
as I mentioned,
we're a hundred percent donation funded and we receive if received donations
from around two and a half million people all around the globe every single
year,
literally all around the globe from very small donations in places you wouldn't
expect to significant contributions from generous folks in your,
our own backyard.
Our current operating budget is around $63 million,
which is,
as I said,
okay,
we're a small nonprofit,
particularly for one that runs such a large website.
And of course it's not just Wikipedia.
So you,
Wikipedia is probably the project that you've heard of.
It's the largest and it's the most popular,
but we run 12 other free knowledge projects as well.
Some of these you might be familiar with wiki quote,
which is a quote resource which scenary a free dictionary.
Wikimedia Commons.
These are incredibly important to the infrastructure of the wicked media
ecosystem of knowledge.
We can media Commons is where you find all of those beautiful images that
illustrate we compete IA articles and we can media Commons er's are just as
enthusiastic and passionate as the editors of the encyclopedia.
In fact,
they run the world's largest photo competition as recognized by the Guinness
Book of World Records every single year to bringing in incredible images from
wiki loves earth and Wiki loves monuments that document our shared human
heritage and then we have other projects like Wiki data which are a little bit
newer and into my mind,
incredibly exciting wiki data.
You could think of it as a structured data backend to all the knowledge that is
contained within Wikimedia media.
We've begun developing it.
It's also all volunteer developed and contributed to and we see it as the future
for beginning.
Being able to run increasingly complex queries and ways finding ways of
engagement for all the knowledge that's on Wikipedia today.
We think that this is the future of where we're going.
And then of course there's MediaWiki.
As I've mentioned earlier,
it's a free and open source wiki software.
It's an application that we,
that we run and maintain.
It's built on a big sticky ball of PHP,
which we love and hate all in equal measure but is also core to our mission
because as you probably know,
PHP is an incredibly easy language for folks to learn.
That's taught all over the world,
which I don't know about,
incredibly easy,
but it's the language,
it's a language that is taught all over the world,
which is core to our mission because it means that no matter where you are you
can contribute back to who we are and the and the underlying platform that runs
us.
And it runs a number of other projects as well,
including ones you may have heard of such as knowledge sharing projects in NASA
and SF Moma.
So I've told you a little bit about where we come from.
I've told you a little bit about how we work and I've told you a little bit
about who the Wikimedia foundation is,
so now I want to share where we're going or where we hope to go in the future.
I want to tell you about that great big vision that keeps we comedians coming
back every single day.
Our vision statement at the Wikimedia media in the Wikimedia movement as we call
ourselves is to imagine a world in which every single human can freely Sha share
in the sum of all knowledge.
Personally,
I think this is pretty profound.
I also recognize that we may never get there,
but that's part of the reason that makes it so compelling.
It's part of why we keep working against it and as I was preparing to come in
today,
I spent some time looking at Google's mission statement and I was reminded of
how much we have in common.
We all believe that information should be available to the world.
We also believe that knowledge is alive and growing and that it is most useful
when it is used,
not just static,
but engaged with built upon,
expanded on.
That's the share in our mission statement.
It's the useful in yours.
We also know that there's so much further that we have to go.
We're nowhere near yet achieving that incredible vision.
Okay.
As I said,
there's so much more to do.
Wikipedia often feels like the universe constantly expanding outwards.
When you dip into an article and start clicking through links,
do you find yourself very quickly expanding outwards,
particularly with your tabs?
Um,
you can find almost anything and it feels like as far as you explore,
it just keeps going.
It feels like we have an article for everything,
but in fact renewer even close.
So English Wikipedia,
which is widely regarded as the most complete,
has 5 million articles,
which sounds like a lot,
but it is not a lot.
So one car,
as I mentioned earlier,
there are a number of different policies as to what goes in and out of
Wikipedia.
But a critical criteria on is the criteria of notability.
Is something notable for whatever it is.
It doesn't mean that it's famous.
It just means is it notable for its contribution to the field that it is in.
And one Wikipedia user user Emi Jrp.
I've never met them,
don't know who they are,
but they keep this wonderful running tally of things worth knowing in the world.
Notable things.
Every major work of art hanging in every major museum,
every village ever settled.
Every scientific discovery,
every book ever written,
every animal or plant that has lived.
Every notable human user.
Emi JRP estimates that there are 17 million notable humans alone.
Okay?
We only have 1.6 million biographies of notable people on Wikipedia,
and this doesn't include all the knowledge that's created every single day
altogether.
User Emi JRP estimates.
There are 104 million and notable things in the world,
and last year this was 91 million.
So the number keeps ticking upwards
as of today.
That means that there are 99 million articles missing from Wikipedia,
okay?
And that's just an English.
That's only 20% we only have 20% of the world's knowledge in English.
Wikipedia today we've barely gotten started
so we know that there is more to do in terms of the knowledge that is being
collected and shared.
We also know that the world is changing.
Our vision doesn't just call on all us for all the world's knowledge and also
Kale calls on us for every single human to freely share in that knowledge.
What does the world look like when we think about every single human,
so we could,
pedia is really big in Russia,
we get about a billion page views every single month and we're huge.
In Japan.
It's the second largest Wikipedia in terms of traffic.
We're also wildly popular in Germany.
We're nearly 80% of German users use us on a regular basis.
These represent some of the biggest and most vibrant of our Wikipedia shows and
yet in 30 years they also represent the places where people,
populations are declining around the world and this is where the world is
growing.
By 2100 the population of the content of the continent of Africa is going to be
around 4.4 billion for our point of reference.
By 2100 the population of the entire world will be just over 10 billion,
which means that the population of Africa,
the continent will be roughly half the population of the world.
And where's Wikipedia on this?
Well,
only 2.2% of our page views come from this continent.
Only 2.5% of content in English.
Wikipedia has anything to do with the African continent.
It's geography,
it's people,
it's history.
And outside of English we have an even bigger distance to make up the largest of
the,
um,
the largest of the solely African languages.
And Wikipedia is,
is your Ruba.
Ruba has about 32,000 articles you but also has about 31 or sorry,
uh,
30 million speakers.
So 31,000 articles for 30 million speakers.
Another enormous African language is Hausa,
which is spoken widely across west Africa.
It is spoken by 44 million people and it only has about 1.4.
Well actually not even one point 1,400 articles and Wikipedia.
That is incredibly what you would think would be incredibly large PR,
which is Arabic.
Wikipedia also spoken on the continent of Africa has only 350,000 articles.
I'm sorry,
450,000 articles for 420 million speakers.
So there is a really big gap between where we are today and where we need to go
in order to actually start to meet that vision statement of every single human.
And why does this all matter?
I mean not just because we're Wikipedia and we want it to matter,
but why does this actually matter?
When we firmly believe that knowledge creates understanding and that in today's
world,
understanding is sorely lacking.
It's something that we should double down on it.
Something that's important.
It's not just for us about learning,
which you can do on every Wikipedia article.
It's also that discourse and finding truth together.
We need spaces for public discourse.
Wikipedia is one of these spaces when multiple viewpoints are shared alongside
of each other for the reasons of why they're there,
we get a clear picture of the truth,
which is exactly how Wikipedia works.
Most people don't realize that when they come to Wikipedia,
they're seeing only about re like roughly 50% of what Wikipedia is.
You're visiting the article,
but behind the article there's something called a talk page and a talk page is
like a public forum on everything that Wikipedia contains.
It's where editors hash it out from the citations to notability to truth to
emerging details of sciences and when things should be incorporated in to what
is common knowledge and science and studies have shown that this process
actually hasn't profound impact on those who participate in it.
It's not just about the content on the article,
but it's about the discourse that goes into the process.
Slanted Wikipedia editors,
people who come in with a bias actually become more neutral over time.
Wikipedia literally can create understanding through editing.
Okay,
and we believe that this is what the world needs today,
that the world needs free,
unbiased knowledge that we need truth and understanding as you know.
Yeah,
information and its reliability has been in the news a lot lately.
Wikipedia has certainly been aware of this conversation.
People are making real life changing decisions based on what they read on the
Internet.
That's kind of scary
as we could pedia.
We want to make sure that the information that you're receiving is accurate,
reliable,
and trustworthy and that we're a place to go to have conversation,
but it's not just about us.
There is an urgency and responsibility to all of our work here in this room.
We know that the web is becoming less open.
We know that privacy is increasingly losery.
We know that the window of public discourse is narrowing globally and that
reliable sources of truth are up for debate.
We believe that what Wikipedia and free knowledge stands for is more important
than ever and the access and participation are our commitment.
Verifiability and neutrality,
discourse and communication resolution perspective in history.
This is what we do and we do it with all of our human flaws because we are
created by people.
We do it pretty well.
Okay?
We also know that we have a lot of work to do.
I showed you some of those trends in the world.
This means that there are great challenges but extraordinary possibilities
ahead.
We will continue to fight for that truth and that understanding and that
knowledge,
but we also want to do it together,
not just in this room,
not just with the folks here at Google and not just at the Wikimedia foundation.
At our core,
we believe that every single human needs to participate in this process.
The premise that given enough eyes,
all bugs are shallow.
That human generosity that I referenced earlier,
that more people want to do good than harm.
That together,
if we work together and if we come to it with commitment to openness that we can
freely share in the sum of all knowledge and increase understanding around the
world.
So we'd ask you to join us in whatever way that makes sense.
We'd ask you to contribute code,
we'd ask you to make an edit,
we'd ask you to make a donation.
We believe that we're in this together and that and together we will find
ourselves in that world in which we imagine so.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
No,
I'm good.
I know you all have a lot of questions for Catherine invites Katherine to have a
seat here and I will start a few questions to warm up and that you ask your
questions.
So just now you said,
uh,
like a fun fact is when you mentioned QHP was a very easy to learn language,
a lot of people until laughter and yeah,
just like,
uh,
there's a lot of opinions here and I want to start with a little one.
Like what's your favorite Wiki page?
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
so my favorite one?
Well,
my favorite Wiki page is a good question.
My favorite Wikipedia article is the overview effect.
As anyone here familiar with the overview effect?
No,
the overview effect is a phenomenon that,
uh,
affects astronauts when they go into space.
The,
um,
as far as sort of reported and described it is the sense sensation when you're
floating above Earth in orbit that the world is very small and very fragile and
that the differences that divide us are much smaller than the differences that
bring us together.
And I,
I've always thought of it as this incredibly beautiful analogy for the world.
Um,
and I also was a really practical one.
You're out there,
you're vulnerable and you're looking at home and home is,
that's it.
It's just home.
It's all of our home.
So that's my favorite article.
My favorite Wikipedia page is a page that it's an essay.
Um,
I mentioned there are 70 pages of essay is probably more,
a lot more books worth of them that Wikipedia editors,
right?
So that 104 million articles,
that's an essay,
the notable things in the world.
But my favorite is actually one that says there is no such thing as a reader.
And what the author meant by that is that there is no such thing as somebody who
reads Wikipedia and comes away with just a transactional interaction because
every reader can become an editor and a contributor.
And we're all changed by the experience of learning.
So that's probably my favorite.
Wow.
That's okay.
Yeah.
So my second question is,
I bet a lot of Google areas will have this same question.
Yeah.
Is that,
uh,
we know that,
um,
Wikipedia we can media foundation is completely based on donation and each year
as I put in my campaign for fundraising,
we could media foundation was one ed almost a one 70th of fun in compared to a,
uh,
a website with a similar traffic.
So how would it be possible for such a large side run on such an efficient fund?
Ooh,
a duct tape sticks.
Glue.
No,
in seriousness,
it is,
it is because first of all,
it's because of the contribution of the many donors who make it possible.
Um,
Wikipedia would not be able to have scaled to the size that we are today without
support.
When we first ran our very first fundraising campaign,
it was practically to keep the servers from overheating and keep the thing on,
um,
as we grew.
But in reality,
I think that it's because everyone who comes to work with the Wikimedia
foundation is just hugely passionate about what they do.
They're there for the mission and they give their all to it.
Um,
and because we are so open,
we get support from folks who are outside of the foundation as well.
So I mentioned the 37 stewards who have pseudo access to the sites.
That's not a joke.
Um,
we actually have people all over the world who are volunteers who are trusted
in,
uh,
in terms of maintaining and managing the sites with us.
And so it's actually through open collaboration with the community that makes it
possible.
But of course we're also just really thirsty because every donor dollar matters
a lot and we have to think a lot about how we prioritize in order to keep the
site's up.
Yeah.
And uh,
another question from me is,
um,
like s such a successful project,
what do you think people can learn from the Wikipedia project nowadays?
I do believe that it is to have faith in people.
I know that that sounds hopelessly simple,
but I think it's true.
I do believe that Wikipedia actually is evidence that more people want to do
good than harm.
It's also evidence that if you give people information,
they can do really good things with it.
We haven't had these challenges that,
for example,
fake news as has it has been in the discourse because we compete,
he is completely open.
If you give people context and the ability to find out where information comes
from,
they generally tend to use that information to make good decisions.
So have faith in people,
be open to collaboration,
be transparent about your intention.
And definitely one that we talk about a lot.
Own it up when you make a mistake.
That's pretty critical in terms of having trust with your users and your
community.
As you talk about like the Wiki data and our [inaudible] team,
like my team is actually the liquid was like knowledge graph indexing system.
And as you mentioned the north data.
I'm just like curious,
curious about is there any ongoing efforts or plan to work with Google?
Because I saw lots of like similar like epilepsy,
dom [inaudible].
Okay.
Pedia and also by Google.
So I'm curious,
is there any efforts or we can do together rather than separate finish up by
Google and by Wikipedia,
right,
sure.
And I think Google can also contribute a lot of data back to Wikipedia.
See?
So will you cure it?
Lots by lots of data from Wikipedia.
So I mean we are really open and interested in finding ways to work with Google.
We've found that we've had a lot of successful collaborations in the past and
actually wiki data,
um,
about two years ago.
Do you remember freebase?
Yes.
Familiar with it.
Right.
So a freebase was,
was I think shut down as a,
but all of the information or the data is the data is still living.
And in fact Wikipedia editors or sorry,
Wiki data editors have been working to take a significant portion of that data
that was contained in freebase and integrated into Wiki data solving for some of
the challenges that freebase hot in terms of building a community and handling
some of the more difficult challenges of taxonomy for the different formats of
data.
So I think I would certainly be interested in thinking about how we could
collaborate together and I'd love to chat afterwards.
Yeah.
Wikipedia has done a great job at curating knowledge and giving an accurate view
of knowledge to the,
to the world.
With the advent of fake news,
do you think there's an opportunity of doing wiki news as a curated method of
offering reliable,
accurate news to the world?
So,
uh,
well full disclosure because it's,
as I mentioned,
we're super transparent.
We can use exists and it has never taken off as a project for a variety of
reasons.
Um,
you can go to new,
like I think it's [inaudible] dot org and you can find different language
versions of it.
My guess is it has a combination to do with um,
some of the challenges that you would see in lesser traffic,
Wikipedia articles you need sort of a critical mass.
But I do think is really interesting is that we could [inaudible] just outside
of Wiki news back on Wikipedia now cause there are different projects have
developed a way of writing articles about breaking news that is tremendously
well trafficked.
Um,
so the first two that I'm aware of as a breaking news story that really sort of
hit the mainstream was unfortunately the shootings at Virginia Tech many years
back.
But,
um,
over the course of time Wikipedians have developed protocols for how to write
breaking news articles that are often cited within sort of the mainstream press
and shared among journalists on Twitter and the like.
And what we have found have been incredible resources,
particularly in times of uncertainty and lack of understanding and in a emerging
news event,
because what we compete Ian's do is they curate from all across all these
different news sources.
So if you imagine in let's say a natural disaster,
you've got all these different news sources on the ground and everybody's
reporting their one perspective on it.
Wikipedians are taking that and making that into holistic survey of all the news
that's out there.
So I've always personally having,
uh,
just based on my own interest in,
in the fourth estate and the,
and the importance of journalism is an entity with an open societies have been
very interested in what we could do to help surface that.
As a reliable resource that is almost like a compliment to individual stories as
they occur.
So I think like a pedia has a role to play and I think it in the,
at the moment editors are very interested in how exactly do we navigate that
without necessarily moving away from sort of the core of who we are.
Um,
in terms of our policies in the like,
would there be any way to like highlight that as a on a newsfeed that sort of
not
yes,
and we've actually been working on developing that.
Uh,
so we now have an API to pull from breaking news events and if anybody is
interested in talking about that,
another product.
So nowadays,
nowadays if you've got the APP downloaded,
you can actually receive alerts when things start breaking because we'll see
based on the surge in traffic and the increase in editors and the creation of a
new article when something is happening in the world.
So it's an app that just does news without the rest of the Wikipedia.
Not yet.
The 277 people makes it really hard to spin off product.
Although certainly it would be something that is actually under the terms of
what we do,
would be open for folks to work on with us and develop it.
You just got to be some alerts.
Media,
sorry you said alerts.
Uh,
yes,
it's,
it's in Beta.
So I'm sorry,
the question was can you actually receive alerts from the Wikipedia App?
And the answer is yes,
it's a,
it's a Beta feature that you can turn on.
Um,
you mentioned that we can,
media is a nonprofit and will always be a nonprofit.
Yeah.
So I was interested,
how do you,
um,
you know,
deal with monetization and um,
what's the guiding principle that keeps you from monetizing at some point down
the road?
And second question was,
um,
you mentioned that a lot of editors,
a lot of articles or an English,
a lot of editors come from the western part of the world and sometimes even
though people will try to be objective,
there's unconscious biases.
And even when you present the facts,
there is a way to promote,
you know,
cause that the facts that promote a,
an opinion that you would favor.
So how do you go about,
I'm just making sure that we have editors from all parts of the world.
So in some way these unconscious biases balanced out.
So the first question is actually the easy one to answer.
Uh,
so back in 2001 when Wikipedia was first created,
there was conversation about should we run ads,
should it be monetized in some way?
And the community of editors at that point were very clear in,
in,
um,
in their decision that it shouldn't be.
In fact,
again,
the skits ins are sort of like the history of Wikipedia.
The Spanish Wikipedia threatened to fork and take all of Spanish Wikipedia away,
um,
with them and less Wikipedia was committed to being a noncommercial nonprofit
organization.
And that's where the history of that comes from.
Uh,
I think that in terms of monetization or at running ads,
you know,
we say never say never,
but no.
Um,
basically because it's really core to the values of our community that they
believe that if we start moving in that direction bias might be introduced
because we might not want to offend an,
you know,
an advertiser or the leg and we would start to grapple with some challenges that
we currently don't have today.
So not running ads for us as core to our independence and independence is what
we believe is core to our model.
Um,
which actually gets a little bit to your second question in terms of how do you
confront bias?
And I think you're absolutely right,
unconscious bias and implicit bias.
It's something we think about a lot,
um,
at,
at the Wikimedia foundation and it's something many of our editors think about
as well.
So in the last year alone,
we've set aside around half a million dollars to a in community grants,
small grants to community members to address issues of,
um,
culture,
toxic behavior,
which might increase prefer example by driving out certain certain contributors,
certain forms of contribution that could address by us ways of encouraging
editors to run events and edit a thons to address bias.
I think that there are now we comedians when they edit Wikipedia,
when they do it as a social event,
they do this thing called an edit.
Ethan,
like a Hackathon,
right?
They're an entire edit Athens that now bring people together to focus on editing
within an article as opposed to creating new articles in order to look for
unconscious bias on a variety of subjects.
We at the foundation are deeply committed to improving diversity in the
projects,
and I don't just mean that in terms of diversity of demographic,
in terms of ethnicity for example,
but diversity of viewpoints,
diversity of backgrounds.
We actually at our conference in North America this year had a cause.
We have these conferences for community members had this wonderful track that
included someone speaking on the importance of supporting Haitian creole as a
Wikipedia language.
Somebody speaking about Trans bias and a ratio of trans people on Wikipedia and
how to edit in sensitivity to that and how to address the persistent gender gap
that exists.
So on Wikipedia today,
I mentioned we have 1.6 million biog million.
No one point,
sorry.
1.3 million biographies of living or notable people,
only 16% of that,
uh,
of those biographies are about women,
which is a huge gap.
It also record reflects a gap in broader society.
So implicit bias is not just something we could pedia deals with.
We rely on secondary sources and if secondary sources aren't written about other
perspectives,
if they are entire swathes of people,
our ma or missing from popular discourse,
then they're probably missing from Wikipedia too.
So we start with our own community,
but we're deeply invested in making sure that folks know that this is a
priority,
not just for Wikipedia,
but advocating for this as a priority around the world and in other forms of
publication and media as well.
That's a great question.
Thank you.
I'm very passionate about it,
so I appreciate you asking it.
All right.
So,
um,
there's a couple of,
I guess,
issues that I know you have to deal with.
So one is controversial pages where,
um,
I mean,
you know,
that they're,
some,
some particular articles when they were sort of freely editable,
people would just,
you know,
you would get completely one sided things there.
There were problems with that.
And then,
um,
so I know that some pages have to have sort of restrictions on editing and the
other,
um,
sort of similar issues that I notice a lot of pages have a have comments at the
top that say that they need cleanup and they need to cite citations and so on.
So for those two sort of issues,
I'm wondering,
do you have sort of plans for dealing with them?
Do you feel like they're getting better over time?
Are they less of an issue?
Are they getting worse?
So a couple of different sort of themes in there.
Uh,
we in a good sort of rule of thumb for Wikipedia article is the more popular it
is,
the more accurate and well cited and um,
and neutral it is going to be,
it's,
it's akin to the formation of a diamond,
right?
You start with carbon and with tremendous amount of pressure,
all those eyes on all those bugs,
it becomes something Krystallynn and clear.
That's kind of how Wikipedia articles work.
So you have the most popular articles tend to be like 300 citations,
350 citations for the article and Barack Obama,
for example.
Um,
the smaller articles that get less traffic,
this,
this remains a challenge.
What we have seen though is if,
for example,
some random smaller article does for some reason end up as part of the public
conversation,
the quality improves very quickly to those articles.
Uh,
we do have Wikipedians who are very focused on improving like citation cleanups,
but we at the foundation have also been working to support this from a product
perspective.
So recently we've collaborated with the Internet archive to clean up every dead
citation on English,
Wikipedia.
And over the course of the year replace,
I think it was a million plus citations that were dead links in order to improve
that verifiability of content.
We've also been working with editors in building and supporting editor created
because we could then we immediate foundation,
we'll build sort of advanced tooling for editors to track new articles and their
creation.
But our community members also build these tools and then we host them in our
own cloud.
It's not,
I know it's not Google cloud,
but we have,
we have our own cloud service called called Wikimedia labs.
And so we work with our editors who build these tools in order to support them
and make sure that we've got a sort of robust systems for ensuring their support
over time.
And those will look at things like how do you improve the,
the triage workflow for new articles?
How do you identify articles with citation issues so that editors can improve
their workflows and automated ways.
We're very passionate in fact about embracing things like machine learning,
which we think are going to really be able to take help Wikipedia editors take
that next step forward.
We talk about doing the things that we talked about,
introducing machines to do the things that humans can,
um,
to do the things that humans can do.
But take away some of those efforts from those more boring sort of wrote
functions in order to allow humans to focus on the really sort of advanced
capacity of the creation of knowledge.
So that sort of a couple of different approaches that we're taking to it.
But it remains,
I mean,
as you said,
it remains something that is a challenge for us over time,
but it's sort of how the model works.
Okay.
So my next question is more about like numbers.
So you pretty much talked a lot about how we keep Edr grown like in the past
where it should be like where the gap is,
but what's your expectation will be the growth rates the next five years and how
do you expect to impact your budget?
I think you mentioned a 63 minutes per year now.
Right?
So what's your expectation?
So for essentially liquidation is like how would you expect,
um,
how efficient do you expect to have a tron by the nation's?
Pretty much,
right?
It depends on the growth rate and what would be the impact on the budget.
Sure.
So,
I mean,
every additional user for us is a net positive in terms of being somebody who
may become a supporter in terms of the budget.
But we recognize that it has to be balanced by both growth in of the overall
base of supporters,
but also increase efficiency on our backend.
Right?
So wiki media Commons,
35 million free images,
I mean that,
that is a lot for us.
We recognize that,
um,
that puts us in the top echelon of media sites,
but it's not nearly the number of photos that other sites handle on a daily
basis.
We would love more rich media on Wiki media.
We also recognize that should that come to pass,
we have a whole new set of exciting challenges in terms of how we,
uh,
support in scale for that.
In terms of our overall projected growth,
we're a little bit unusual in that the only thing that we have to sort of
measure for is our progress against our mission.
So we're not necessarily tracking about how we enter into markets or how quickly
we're growing as,
um,
as,
as sort of a main metric for,
um,
for our shareholders or anything like that.
Uh,
we have tried more aggressive approaches into entering into new markets and
found that really it actually from our perspective,
because we are a combination of community content and readers,
it has to be something that's more organic.
It doesn't work,
for example,
to try to do a big push in Nigeria,
which is a hugely interesting market of individuals,
right?
It gets incredibly middle income.
It's growing.
It's a quarter of the African Po continence population.
If we don't have content that people can read in the languages in which they
prefer to read.
So I mentioned how's a,
I mentioned Jaruba.
These are two very popular languages in Nigeria.
Igbo is another one.
We've got English,
Wikipedia,
but English Wikipedia to the previous question about implicit bias doesn't
necessarily contain all of the things that folks would want to read.
So for us it's sort of this,
this,
um,
art rather than science and how do we grow communities so that they're writing
the articles that folks are interested in,
the articles that are notable to a community,
a while.
Also thinking about how do we reach out into places where we're not yet in order
to grow.
So right now we have a team that's focused on going into,
I'm focused on what we call our new route new readers project,
which is looking at places where we know we have content in the languages,
but we would like to see greater growth in terms of reader adoption.
So no hard numbers per se,
but it's something we're very focused on because it's part of the core mission
and then the growth.
Um,
in terms of financial support,
we're just going to keep working on reducing,
reducing the server load.
I mean,
in reality we're actually quite small.
I don't think folks necessarily realize this.
We're just a couple racks in a colo down in,
in Texas and Virginia.
Right?
I know everyone's like,
Whoa,
just a couple of racks.
Yet we're really just in terms of the Vac,
the fact that we're tech space content,
we're pretty lightweight.
Um,
so that would be a great problem for us to have.
We'd like to have that problem.
I just would also really just want to say thank you.
You've been an incredible audience.
I've really appreciated all the questions and your attention as I've been
talking and your offers of support and help.
So thank you so much.
We really were.
We're just greatly appreciate it to,
we have a lot in common and we're glad to be able to have these conversations.
I think that's,
uh,
thank them again for coming.